Hey everyone, how's it going.
My name is Mayuko,
and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech, career, and life.
so I asked my Twitch stream the other
day what video y'all want to see,
and a lot of you were interested
on 'What's on my Mac'.
I made a 'What's on my iPhone' video
a couple months ago, and so today,
I'm going to show you all of
the things that I use on my Mac
and how I use it. This will include Mac
applications that I use on a day-to-day basis,
as well as the functionality and
features of Mac OS that I use all the time.
And yes, it's Mac, not PC.
If you put a PC in front of me,
I wouldn't know what to do with it, 'cause
I've used a Mac since I was like...
seven or something. My dad was really
into Apple computers from the early days,
and so I've just kind of like
kept going with that. And now look at me!
I had a career as an iOS developer,
and I'm like fully in the Apple ecosystem
at this point. And just a little background
before we get started, I use the Macbook Pro.
I have the 15-inch model because
I bought it in mid 2018
before the 16-inch model came out.
The processor is a 2.9 gigahertz, 6 core
Intel Core i9. It's got 32 gigs of memory
and 1 terabyte of storage.
When I bought it, I wanted to do
kind of a lot of things,
I wanted it to handle iOS development
super smoothly, and also video editing.
So it's kind of like a souped up version
of a Macbook Pro.
The next year up after this is probably
like an iMac or iMac Pro,
but I'm pretty happy with what I've
got right now.
So without further ado, let's dive in.
So the first thing I'm going to show you
are just features of Mac OS
that I really enjoy using.
You may or may not know about them,
but these are the ones that kind of have
made it into my workflow.
[DO NOT DISTURB - MAC FEATURE]
So the first thing is Do Not Disturb mode.
There's a lot of notifications that
come flying through on my Mac,
and when I need a little bit of
focus time, and I don't want to see
what emails are coming through or
Slack messages or Discord messages,
then this is really handy.
Also, when I'm like in a phone call,
on a Zoom call or something, then
being able to silence everything
so that I am completely
focused on the task at hand
is something that has really
helped me to get my stuff done.
And right next to
Do Not Disturb mode,
[NIGHT SHIFT - MAC FEATURE]
is Night Shift. now I used f.lux before
the invention of Night Shift on Mac OS,
but it really does help me with my eyes.
I have mine set to a schedule where
I have it turned on at sunset,
and then turned on until sunrise.
I kind of like my screen to be a little
bit warmer. Like my eyes are already very
bad, so they're doing a lot of work to
concentrate on a screen right in front of me.
And so taking away the blue light
definitely helps with my eyes so that
I can fall asleep at night.
And I know like, blue light stuff,
there's like a lot of competing debates
about it, but really I have noticed
that since using Night Shift,
I don't feel my eyeballs in my eyes
when I'm trying to fall asleep.
And so I have Night Shift on my Mac and
I also have it on my phone.
And sometimes if my eyes are just tired
I'll just turn it on the middle of the day.
Like it really does just help
relieve my eye of that strain.
The next thing I want to show you is
Spotlight.
[SPOTLIGHT - MAC FEATURE]
So, unless you've changed the settings on your own Mac,
then you can trigger Spotlight
with Command + Space.
I have mine set so that'll search
through applications, which really is
what I primarily use it for.
And so, instead of digging through
like the applications folder
and trying to find what you need,
being able to go to Spotlight search and
then type exactly what I need and then
press Enter, and it launches thing
makes it super easy.
Its origins are in something called
Alfred that a lot of people used at
the time that Apple adopted, and
it's made my workflow a lot easier and
it really helps. You can have it set
to search through your
different files as well as different text.
It can also even do math for you,
which is really nice.
Uh, and so that's just like a really
handy thing to have at your
fingertips. Another thing that
I really like using that's part
of Mac OS is Spaces.
[SPACES - MAC FEATURE]
I have a lot of spaces all the time,
and usually there's like an
application per space. And I like this
because I like having full screen
windows for everything,
and it's easier for me to navigate
between different spaces than it is
to navigate between
different applications.
So I usually have one for
video editing,
another one for browsing the internet,
another one for
text communication like Discord and
WhatsApp. And I usually also have one for
Spotify. I can always add more spaces,
I can also take them away.
And it's just been a good way to
organize all of my thoughts and
the applications that are running
on my computer.
So those are the features that I enjoy
that are part of Mac OS.
Right now, I'm using Mac OS Catalina, and
I'm really excited to use Mac OS Big Sur,
as well as future releases to see what
functionality Apple adds to Mac OS.
While we're on the topic of
'What's on my Mac',
I want to talk about one of my favorite
websites on my Mac which is Brilliant,
who is a sponsor of today's video.
Brilliant is an amazing website and app
that makes learning super accessible
and fun. Their whole approach
is based on problem solving and
active learning, which I think
is really kind of one of the
best ways to learn new things.
They teach you concepts visually with
interactions to help you better understand,
and then also ask you questions, so
that you're engaging with the topic
and content. And unlike school,
there's like, no tests, no grades,
it's literally just to fulfill and
enrich your learning.
They've got a ton of courses in math,
science, and computer science.
One that I'm really interested
in that i'm going to take is
the knowledge and uncertainty course.
This course gives you the mathematical
tools for dealing with the flood of
information in our lives.
And you'll learn cutting edge
mathematics like information theory,
Bayesian networks, and causal inference
but in an accessible way without
the calculations getting in the way.
They've also got a lot of great courses
in computer science as well,
so whether you want to brush up on your
fundamentals and your algorithms or
you want to dive into something
like Python or even cryptography,
they've got it. So try out Brilliant today
by going to brilliant.org/hellomayuko,
and only the first 200 subscribers
will get 20 percent off
the annual premium subscription.
Thanks so much for Brilliant for sponsoring,
and let's get back to the video.
So next, we're going to talk about
applications. So I have all of the
applications that I use on
a day-to-day basis in my dock,
which shows and hides if I go
to the bottom of the screen.
So we're going to start with Brave.
Brave is a is a Chromium-based browser
that really emphasizes privacy.
It comes with built-in ad blockers and
everything, and so it's been really
easy to use, and I feel good using it
because it blocks all of these ads
for me to begin with.
I actually used to use Safari because
Safari is also really good for privacy,
but a lot of websites are built on top
of Chromium, and web developers are
mostly focused on delivering a
good experience on Chrome
and not so much Safari,
which is why I've been using Brave.
I have my bookmarks at the top,
and I have a couple of extensions, but
that's just, that's kind of my web browser –
there's not really a whole lot to it there.
So next, let's talk about email.
[SPARK - EMAIL]
I've been using Spark – I use it on my phone,
and I use the calendar for it as well.
I used to just use the web browser
for Gmail and then also
the Mail client on Mac, but
I needed something that was
a desktop app that also divided my email
just like how Gmail does. I like that
I can pin messages on Spark,
and that it divides my newsletters,
as well as my notifications.
And the calendar app's
pretty intuitive too.
There are some things that
I don't really like about Spark in that
I can't completely make my
17,000 newsletters marked as read,
and I don't think this email client is
for everybody.
If there is like a more elegant solution
in the future that I enjoy using,
then I think I'll hop to that.
But for now, this meets my needs.
next we're going to talk about my
project management tools,
mainly ClickUp and Trello.
[CLICKUP - PROJECT MANAGEMENT]
So I talked about both of these apps in the video
where I talk about how
I organize my life, but
these are the two main things that
I use to organize all the tasks
and projects that are going on.
I really like that ClickUp has
a dedicated Mac app, because then it
doesn't get lost in all of my browser tabs,
and it's really just easy to access.
It does all the things
That the web app does,
and I just kind of have it in a space
somewhere so that I can always
look at it if I need to.
[TRELLO - PROJECT MANAGEMENT]
and in addition to ClickUp, I also use Trello.
So, I use Trello mostly for
projects that I'm working on with
other people, and it's just a lot more
lightweight than ClickUp, and so
for simple projects, it's been
really good to have this on hand.
Next, we're gonna go
into video editing things.
[VIDEO EDITING - ADOBE PREMIERE PRO]
So, I use Premiere Pro. I used to use Final Cut,
but then I moved to
Premiere Pro because
there's just a lot more tutorials out there
on how to use Premiere Pro,
and while the learning curve for Adobe
products is always really big, I feel
pretty comfortable with it now, and it does
all the things that I want it to and more.
It's been really nice because I also have
the Logitech MX Keys,
and the MX Master 3. And so
I've programmed my mouse and
keyboard with specific key bindings
to work for Premiere.
And that's really improved my
editing workflow, it's made it so much
faster, and it's a lot easier to edit videos.
so that's Premiere. Next,
I'm going to talk about Figma.
[FIGMA - DESIGN]
So Figma is a tool used by designers.
A lot of UI/UX designers use Figma
or Sketch in order to create
mock-ups for apps and websites, but I use
it mostly to create thumbnails
and other assets I might need for
my videos and content creation.
So for instance, I made all of my merch
on this, as well as all of my overlays
for Twitch, and then also assets
for Code With Friends.
It's pretty intuitive to use,
it's pretty easy to collaborate
with other people on it.
Again, I really appreciate it that it's
its own Mac app, because I don't like
using these heavy tools on web.
Because again, it'll get lost in my
tabs, or it's just not as efficient,
and so being able to use it as a Mac app,
regardless of how it's built underneath,
has been a really good thing
for my workflow.
All right, so next we'll talk about
my coding tool. So I'm
an iOS developer, so literally, like
the main IDE that I would use is Xcode.
[XCODE - Coding]
I have it on my dock at the bottom, and,
if you're going to make iOS apps,
you have to use Xcode.
I don't really got a choice, and so... yeah.
It's there. Right now, I'm on 12.0.1,
and... yeah. it's easy to access it's,
it's how you write Apple apps.
And for everything that's not
iOS development, then I use
[VISUAL STUDIO CODE - CODING]
Visual Studio Code.
I've been through all the iterations of
going from Sublime to Atom,
and it seems like now Visual Studio
Code is like the de facto code editor.
And I like it a lot. I like that I can
add extensions to it, the organization of
everything is really easy.
Being able to preview markup files has
been a real life saver as well.
I'm not really a heavy user of
Visual Studio Code, because I'm not a
web developer, but I know that a lot of
web developers like using this and it's a
really powerful product if you want to
use it that way.
Next on the dock, we've got Spotify.
[SPOTIFY - MUSIC]
Usually when I'm listening to music,
I'm usually on Spotify, because
that's where all of my music is, Spotify.
[NOTES - NOTES...]
Now, next is Notes. So in the
video where I talk about how
I organize my life, I talk about
the various note-taking systems
that I have. And the Notes app, I use it
as just kind of like a note-taking dump.
I use it as like a scratch pad really
to like copy & paste Instagram
captions, as well as just like
quick To-Do lists as well.
And so, just having a place that I can go
to just like write something out
really fast, right on my doc is why Notes
is one of my most used apps on Mac.
Honestly, I should probably go and like
clear a lot of things out, because
there's just a lot of random notes in
here that make zero sense.
So that's Notes.
Next, I've got my slew of
communication tools.
[MESSAGES - TEXTING]
So I have Messages on here, so I can like
talk to my friends during the workday.
[DISCORD - MESSAGING]
I've also got Discord, because I have my own server
for people who
watch my Twitch stream.
[SLACK - Messaging]
And then I've got Slack because I just belong to
I feel like so many different
and random Slack groups,
and keep in touch with folks
every once in a while.
[ZOOM - Messaging]
I also have Zoom down here because
our life is like on Zoom nowadays,
since we're in quarantine,
and I use it at least once a day.
And then I also have WhatsApp.
[WHATSAPP - Messaging]
Mostly to communicate with my brand manager,
as well as people who live overseas.
Lastly, I've got LastPass, which
is my password manager.
[LASTPASS - Password Management]
Just having it there so I can either
generate a new password or
copy & paste an existing one.
Has made it super easy.
I also have the Chrome extension
for LastPass as well, but that also
deserves a spot on my dock.
We're gonna skip over Quicktime Player.
It's usually not in my dock, but it's
there, just because I'm recording
my screen right now.
But, next are the folders that I have.
And in that, I've got Downloads.
A lot of the stuff that I draw on my
iPad, I AirDrop to my computer which then
lands in Downloads, and having
this fan out view has been really
easy to work with, because
then I can just grab things
that have been downloaded to my
computer or AirDropped.
I've also got my Dropbox folder,
because I put a lot of my
business things in there.
And then I also have my Videos folder.
This just makes it super easy for when
I'm video editing and I need like a
quick asset or something.
It's just there within reach.
Oh, one last thing that I forgot: for
keyboards, I have the US English keyboard,
and then I also have the hiragana
keyboard for when I type Japanese.
That's also up there so that's easy
within reach that I can
flip between the different languages
very quickly.
And that's it!
Thank you all so much for watching
this video. I hope you liked it,
I hope you found out
about a new application or two
that maybe you'd consider using.
Let me know what features or
applications you like to use on your Mac
in the comments down below.
And make sure to subscribe to my channel
if you'd like to see more videos from me,
and I will see you next time.